皆さんはああ
風邪をひいたことはあったろう
水を引いた自分と別に体は元気だが心だとか
そういった経験がある人もいるだろう心と体のバランスが取れていない状態である
そんな状態の
一人の男の話である
お母ん
をする
をへ
みんな大丈夫か俺は大丈夫だ左腕
お前は何とか無事だ血圧も安定している
俺様がピンピンしてるぜなぁ相棒よ
当たり前だ
貴様誰に口を聞いている良かった
他の皆は的によるダメージがありますがなんとか無事です
ご心配ありがとうございます体調気にするな
お前がやられては俺たちは全滅だ
今後ともよろしく頼むぞ了解で司令部
無事か
熱によるダメージで正常な判断ができないかもしれない
ん
すまないはじめだ
大丈夫か
みんなの無事が確認出来次第すぐ休ませるからもう少し頑張ってくれありがとう
よろしく頼んだかえええええ左腕
頼んだ葉仕方ねぇ
どうだふぅ
生き返る全基動作みんな何とか打つのようだがどうする
そうだな
1罰みんなの確認が取れたが脳だけがまだ状態が良くない
1回全休んで合図を休ませる必要がある
助けてー
誰だ
あ
ぶーうっっこの声を吐くわいんだよはいすいこど恋は間違いねぇ
だけかハァハァ当たり勝った助けてー
どうだ
どうやら喉が渇いているようですね[ __ ]
完全に盲点だったフォアうん俺たちが力を合わせてあいつを助けるしかねーだろ
そうだ俺達ならいけるでも脳がそうだよ
ここで6でしたら脳が俺のことは
大丈夫だのう
俺のことは大丈夫だから
水をグラディ no 3むつ市内でみろよ
no もう限界だだからて悩みってるっていうのか
これは俺たちの奴にも関わるんだからどんなことも考えてくださいよ
めちゃですよいまやのか俺たちならコンビニまでいけるんだよ俺たちがやらなきゃそれ
がないってんだよなぁ
じゃあ何とかしてくれよそれなら俺たちが行くが経ちて言って言わばキャーキャー
頭に血が上って余計な胸はフォア
をへ
みんなやめてくれ
俺は
俺はみんなを救いたい
ここで水を取りに行かなければどうぞやられちまん
ダガー
これ以上この体で移動すると
脳がどうなるか分からね僕たちはどうすればみんな
大丈夫だ
大丈夫そうだ
俺のことは気にせつ
はやく
のどに水を教 no
始め
えっ
お前が決めるんだ
俺たちわー
お前でしたがー
ありがとう
右腕
リゾルトみんな能のためにも喉のためにもみんなで力を合わせてコンビニに行って水を
買いに行くしかない限りません
水もらっていい
me
あっはぁ